[Music]
foreign
[Music]
was the first time you became aware
of what his plan was or where he was at
or that he was walking around with that
kind of hatred
to be honest timeline I don't remember
but I was hearing the rumor for quite
some time as I said I'm a pretty busy
person sure it was happening for a while
and I don't know that they that he had
come and then the second the second time
that I met him in the center and then
the time frame that I invited him over
because the rumor was getting bigger
what was that what was the rumor that
you heard
that he is planning to hurt us to do the
bomb what was that but that rumor that
was based on people's fear people sort
of saying he's in a certain way but but
but at a certain point I imagine you
revealed to the community you know how
did that happen yes what made you decide
to reveal that and where you know how
how was that received
um what was that Phoebe's house
you confronted him right yeah yeah I
think that happened to her house yes
when she confronted me yes and you know
I I think that's what things kind of
chair I mean I know the welcome in the
center the greeting and the hugging of
the legs or giving Comfort I think that
was the time that he he shared with me
when I asked him I said this is what I
heard is that true like you know you're
hurting it and who was BB to you who was
who who was she to you at that moment
when she confronted you
hmm
it's a good question uh
well she was
more my friend than my enemy
she was I was I was slowly you know I
was
I was
falling in love with her family
who actually to be honest with you
they are my family now that you know I
still have a strange relationship with
my own biological family
they're my family
hey that's why it doesn't bother me so
much yeah I I recently just got married
right
Sauber perform because and she's a she's
a devout Christian right we have same
mindset that's why it works so well
uh we had a Christian and an Islamic
ceremony saber performed the Islamic
ceremony bibi's husband yeah bibi's
husband and she did the cooking
I was gonna have it catered I was going
to have a cater because I wanted her to
just because I know what she's always on
the go she's working right all the time
and I just wanted to enjoy it and relax
just kind of got a little
Stephanie told me that she kind of got
her feelings hurt and and I was like
well fine go ahead I mean you know I
just wanted her to sit and enjoy it but
yeah you know but but this this this
confrontation that you talk about can
you talk about what like the tenor of
the com it was just hey I'm hearing this
what's what's what's the truth yeah I
think it was beautiful the way I
remember the whole we are sitting on a
big dining table like 10 of us I don't
know this is public it was in front of
people oh yeah no no no because I mean
the concern was there yeah and these
people I mean like maybe they're not
even afraid to even talk to him some of
them that was like then when I sat down
I just I'm all about breaking ice okay
if there is a conflict between some of
the community leaders I invite them
together and I just kind of like say
let's talk about our community I love it
and I love my community and that's what
exactly what I did as soon as I sat down
I say okay what are you thinking are you
trying to broke the ice and everybody
start the conversation he openly he is a
very open person and he openly shared it
with everyone everybody's listening I
could see the reaction of those people
their faces but it was how it ended it
was just beautiful how did it end
because the understanding came to a
different level
because he expressed it very simply that
this was my plane but I'm thinking
differently meeting you guys how you
guys greet me how you made me understand
even the humanity part
I think the the end of the dinner time I
think the situation was different
and then of course then continuously
with the community and more activities
as I said sometime I will cook dinner
I'll say okay brother Mike you can stop
by I have food for you you come and pick
it up and just to deliver it to him huh
because I know he would need that and he
was by him oh no then I was there and
Emily and I'll just give him extra food
because she was working then I became my
good friend
ex-wife Dana and she was uh my good
friend we had a great time she worked
Easter at Macy's store and I love Macy's
store and I always chat with her every
time I go but anyway that's how it was
kind of ended very nicely with that
evening I mean I personally was in peace
that I was happy that I was able to
invite these people and invite him to
just talk to them did the plan and that
night
oh it started ending it started ending
but yeah I mean was there any the hatred
was gone
uh
and it was gone quickly which is which
has raised a lot of questions uh what
questions look like
you were going to blow this place up
kill all these people
two months later you're okay and
everything's peachy King
you know it what that's crazy but yes
but what does that tell us like what
what does that tell us about all these
people out there who are being led by
their fears their hatred there's
something to that because I I I found
that a lot it's like once you make that
little shift you're actually what the
hell I can't believe that of course that
was so stupid
and
so
um you know it it it had a lot to do
with of course I was I was in search of
something and I think her son Zaki said
it best that I was I was missing
uh being a part of something bigger than
myself I think he probably hit the hit
or the nail right on the head right
there that was that was it and and uh
they they gave me a second chance
what happened after that with my
conversion that that really is just that
was my own personal Journey thing and
that it was all God's plan I I truly
believe that uh but
um the the fact of of getting out of the
hatred you know I I've been called a
hero several times a lot
baby's the hero my daughter is the hero
I was just a tool or just a tool and a
cog man really you know uh they're the
ones that created the change you know
um and it was because of their actions
because of their love
for me as a human well yeah for me as a
human being you know and that's what I
was missing I was I did not have love
for Humanity I did not have love for
human beings you know it was so much
easier like you had said earlier so much
easier to hate and be mad than it is to
be nice and show love it's so much
easier
and I went I took the easy way out and
that's what I was doing they changed my
mind they made me see life as something
else and that's why this the this film
is such a call to action because it
makes you think change is possible man
yeah two months wow that's crazy
yeah I can't explain that God's plan
that's that's all I can say man I know
it's a kind of a cop-out answer but
that's all I can say at some point
you decided hey I'm I'm I want to join
this Faith well and and that had to do
with reading the Quran okay uh and
getting the explanations you know coming
across certain verses and certain
things and one of my favorite favorite
verses is uh or actually it's a it's a
considered a chapter even though it's
very short
uh is explains to me to me when I read
it it explained coexistence
and basically what it does is is it
tells
I don't believe the way you believe you
don't believe the way I believe I will
never believe the way you believe and
you will never believe the way I believe
you go your way I go mine
that's it done deal and I'm reading that
and I'm thinking about these extremists
and I'm like wait a minute
wait a minute
this is it's telling the exact opposite
of their actions
and I love this
I do this is finally this has hit me and
I love this I want to be a part of it
and I think when he came to the center
uh at one point that my husband told me
that's again his uh side of the story
that now he's ready to convert and he
and I remember he's told me that he said
no no no no you keep reading and this is
not time I need to know more you need to
educate yourself more before you do that
I think he told him that in the center
and send him maybe with additional books
keep reading more about it and send him
home Max a passionate guy when he gets
into something
yeah he gets it no no what what no what
what is the story I hear because you
know the whole you know how you're
forced to to to uh to uh convert and all
that the all the horror stories that we
hear and everything like that so it's
funny so I actually go to the Masjid the
the the center of the mosque and and I
go there with the intent that Friday
to make my conversion to say shahada
your Declaration of Faith right to say
that
and I go up to sovere and I think it was
Dr benkatu was standing next to him I
think it was another
early earlier founding brother right and
he was all part of all that and they're
standing next to each other and I tell
him I says
I'm ready to be a Muslim
and they just stood there and they
looked at me they looked at each other
and he looked back at me and they go no
and I never forget that because I'm like
well so much for that converter
and and they said brother brother you
have much more to learn and I says don't
we all
and they looked at each other again
they're like
he got us all right come on
yeah
wow yeah so
that that's always been a funny story
because they just yeah I don't think so
foreign
[Music]